if you're watching this video that means
you are interested in playing as Moe's
in Borderlands 3 I'm joined by mass
Pinelli who is our Moe's expert at the
GameSpot office yes that's me I played a
lot of modes so we're gonna break down
all of Moses skill trees some best tips
and skills you might want to use and
what guns are good for modes Matt let's
start with her three different skill
trees
okay so Moe's the way her skill trees
work they're all kind of oriented around
her iron bear which is her giant mech
thing that she can get into that's kind
of her action skill so the through trees
err is such so she has bottomless mags
which is it's it's kind of a tree that's
focused on really sort of elevating
Moses ability to be as aggressive and
scrappy as a fighter or just you know as
a like a soldier right so you have all
these skills that like essentially make
it so like you're incredibly quick at
handling your weapon reloading and also
like where your ant week was that where
your magazines are essentially extended
okay just keep shooting really fast as
possible exactly that kind of stuff and
then she has demolition woman which is
more focused on on explosives she's got
a lot of skills in that tree that
particularly like leveraged her like
Splash Damage
I keep like sort of amplifying that
effect UNAIDS rocket launcher is that
kind of thing yes exactly
and then lastly she has shield of
retribution which is it's just because
this is kind of where it comes into the
like aspect of Mo's where she acts as a
tank right you know with the iron bear
you are clearly like a huge powerful
target and so when you some of that in
enemies will pay attention to you so the
most of the skills in there Orient's
around kind of Minh surround like
working with your friends you know
there's things in there she has like
some skills that amplify for example
like the damage that her friends will do
so this kind of gets into discussion
about what's kind of associated with
each tree so she has like a like a skill
in there that basically gives her like
this claw that you can grab and she can
like basically grab enemies and then
like have her friends shoot them and so
okay yeah so so each tree is has its own
like associated weapon that that is
- that you can attach onto the iron bear
so bottomless mags has a minigun
demolition woman has a grenade launcher
and Shield of retribution has a railgun
okay that makes sense that all lines up
with what each skill tree dies so what
was the skill tree that you ended up
focusing on bottomless bags that makes
sense you were playing at single-player
yeah it's to just focus on how to make
mmo's as powerful as possible
exactly exactly it was kind of a mix of
bombs mags and demolition woman just cuz
you know I kind of since house playing
solo my play style is just like shoot
dudes as much as possible and like
inflicts a bunch of damage and then when
things were getting like you know Harry
I would get insid likes over the iron
bear or I'm just getting the iron bear
just be like you know like and just sort
of amplifying the amount of damage I'm
putting out there at all time right like
one of the particular skills that are
really great in pub miss mags is rushing
off fencing which is essentially you can
just shoot while sprinting oh so yeah so
you're just crazy fast and you're
shooting at the same time and it's great
it's like you're just constantly laying
down damage I know this is like I'm
saying this a bunch but this is
literally what Mose is all about and
she's just so scrappy which speaking of
which that's another great skill and the
embalm 'less mags which is scrappy which
is which was it like each time you
upgrade this skill increases her
handling speed her weapon swap and her
mode switch on her guns okay Wow cool so
I definitely bottomless mags me playing
solo seems like the way to go yeah
totally so then demolition woman why
would someone want to pick that
particular dream because it focuses on
explosives and that's kind of another
fun part right affect the chaos of like
playing somebody who is so offensive so
you know of course that leverage is sort
of the grenade launcher on the iron bear
but also you know use rocket launchers
right
it just keeps like increasing the amount
of damage from just blast damage of the
splash damage for example like she has a
skill that's called Torg
cross-promotion which increases the
chance of doubling her splash damage at
all okay then the last treat shield the
retribution seems like that's the tree
you probably want to go down if you're
playing with
friends but maybe isn't as useful
playing solo yeah I would say there
wasn't a lot for me in that tree aside
from maybe was it security bear which
kind of gives you like gives iron bear
as a shield which kind of it increases
the amount of time that you could be an
iron bear but aside from that yeah there
wasn't really a lot of useful things for
solo players big right but then when
you're playing with friends that seems
like maybe a potentially useful tree to
go down yeah exactly as I said
previously there were skills there that
amplify your friends like I am or my
sort of there gun damage forget the
scale but there's a lot that does things
in that sort of capacity yeah would you
say that that tree particular makes Mo's
a very like strong support character
versus the other vault hunters which I
really don't have quite maybe as strong
of a a support specific tree yeah I
would say so because it seems so focused
on that because there's a lot in there
that that focuses on on improving that
part of like sort of increasing sort of
the the effectiveness of the team and of
course iron bear is so it to use it as a
tank makes so much sense right because
like it really does call tension on to
your character and you could just lead
the charge and didn't have your buddies
just shooting right beside you heck they
could even get on top of you if you on
top of the iron bear so you can
essentially stat like a like a man
turret on there though I think that's
actually in the bottomless mags skill
tree okay yeah so last thing is weapons
what do you think are the ideal weapon
types brands that are most effective
with those machine guns assault rifles
shotguns if you're loved getting really
close because you're mostly gonna be
pretty close up to the end to your
enemies okay and of course if you're
doing demolition when you do want to rot
like a rocket launcher and you're and
your loadout just so you can take
advantage of just the amount of power
and like the Splash Damage
well thank you for watching everybody if
you're interested in the other
Borderlands characters we have
individual guys on all of them along
with a witch vault hunter is right for
you video that is a nice overview on all
four vault hunters thanks for watching